Iceland is full of stories.
As a National Geographic
photographer,
I voyage across the circumpolar Arctic,
immersing myself
in some of the most raw yet
beautiful places on the planet.
For this adventure,
I'm exploring Iceland in winter.
This time of year,
the land is covered in darkness.
I'm on a journey to find the rare glimpses
of light in the midst of that darkness
that revealed
just how incredible this place is.
Thousands of winters
are written into Iceland's glaciers,
embedded into each layer of ice as it is
formed
in the low light of evening.
I walk deep into the glacier's heart.
I'm traveling through time.
The most ancient ice is the clearest
and bluest.
The color and shape is what draws me in.
As the dim evening light
turns to complete darkness,
I come upon a wrecked DC-3 airplane
from decades ago, revealed by the
light of the aurora borealis.
The darkness recedes just
enough to see the landscapes
take shape again.
The small northern island,
with its fresh volcanic landscape,
is full of the push
and pull of mighty forces.
Mountains
rise out of the sea in dramatic shape.
And where water touches Earth,
it becomes a sculptor,
drawing tracks and trails as it cascades
across the volcanic rocks.
As the light of the sun begins
to appear again,
my journey has come full circle.
The light that reaches my camera's
eye is just a few photons,
but those photons are a million years old,
and they speak to me.
That's just it.
The darkness slows me down.
The photographic process slows me down,
enough to listen to the stories
that the land has to tell.
Free of professional kit
and lighting and crew,
it's just me
and the Oppo Find X5 Pro, listening.
And when I've learned to listen, each
photograph transcends a single moment,
a window into the past
that illuminates our vision of the future.